well we've only worked this once to get
well actually no we've worked
yeah we've worked together before
specifically twelve years ago on
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy yeah
films an art director and I designed it
and this time as code co-designers and
obviously we've taken different paths so
I mean I've been designing probably for
I think it's about 21 years or 22 years
I'm always attracted to things that were
part of what I started doing which
involved the effects and puppets and
weird stuff have huge challenges to them
rather than you just go in and you know
that's going to be an easy one I think
that's the start point so when I see a
project if it's really complicated
I'm usually drawn to it and then regret
every bit of being drawn to it from that
point on until it's finished and then
miss it terribly so this was an
opportunity for me to break away briefly
from our directing anomaly by day I'm a
director on films at the moment and Joel
were kindly offered me in a moment where
the project I was working on went down
and he offered me the chance to
collaborate with him on this which is
great and the starting point for me I
guess was reading the script and I've
heard for a couple years from Joel and
his his business partner Dan how
fantastically scripts were these black
Mary scripts read the script and it
sounds sort of super fancy but it
genuinely was the best thing I've had a
chance to read in a long time being able
to collaborate with Joel was great and
it was kind of being welcomed to a
family so it was a sort of introduction
to design something like this it was
fantastic
on black mirror I think what I've done
over the years is one of the setups for
me to be able to be part of the black
mirror creative process from the title
sequence of the video effects to the
design of the shows was the the
acceptance that directors are going to
come and go and therefore I needed to
engage in really good talented cast
brilliant talent to collaborate with
through each film a big percentage I did
without collaborator and you know it's
kind of a probably a 60/40 split and I
saw a cast very carefully people I liked
people who had brilliant talents in
their areas art directors supervising
art directors who are just unbelievable
in specific
genre or just were were clearly talents
that needed to break out or designers
who were already broken out we're just
going to bring it to front have fun to
play with it on Black Mirror and so in
when I cut I've been I've been kind of
teasing with Phil to try and get him on
board for a while and so yeah this was
this was brilliant for us to collaborate
I think there's so many different routes
I meet so many different designs I mean
art directors who never break out of art
directing and I meet designers who have
come from art and architecture and all
different routes and then there's that's
this there's so many different ways in
and it's so busy with the kind of
contemporary with the situation we're in
now with television it's so busy and
there was a kind of big wall promotion
thing going on and one of the things
with Phil for instances you know you see
people going up the ranks quickly now
and and say with our relationship it was
it wasn't about a promotion it was
actually just he's brilliant so I wanted
Bob with me working on the show but what
what I would say to people is for an
aspiring designer the one thing I say is
think about the bigger picture never
think about never never never be a woman
or a man who's trained and ends up
putting a chair in the middle of a
studio that's green and you don't know
what the world around that chair is so
number one design entirely every
building from the floor to the sky never
do the first floor and a VFX company
look after the rest of it always look at
it as the big picture even if you are
only doing your small bit in camera and
and never tell a designer that you're a
designer so when you graduate as a
production designer for instance never
put a production designer on your CV and
so the key is every designer once a
whole team of designers working with
them but they never want them all to
recall designers ultimately I got fill
in as early as I could in fact we were
working together on the show before Toby
Haynes so before the director was there
Phil understands this genre brilliantly
and we've done spaceships together
before and and so and we know each other
very well and I think the the there's no
ego between us I'd like to think because
we're friends and so there was no
complexity on that level
we'd started we actually started
building a set before Toby started the
project as well I don't know how that
feels for a director walking through a
situation but but it certainly hasn't
happened that way for me working on on
other projects and it meant that from it
from that particular episode of black
Miriah this point of view we could put a
lot of production value into the into
the episode and I think if we do one
o'clock down if you like and had to and
go through a more sort of protracted
development period which is common and
understandable for lots of reasons we
wouldn't have been able to achieve the
look of many other sets and locations
that we we worked on so it meant we
could navigate that sort of stuff and
that at the beginning of the project
Joel creates mood boards for every
episode even if they'd say if you're not
sure how he how much involvement he's
going to have directly because then he
can kind of get a shape of the show he
knows who he's got to sort of bring in
to help design an episode or two
yeah there's tone setting processes I go
through on the show I've gone through
the Charlie and Annabelle so often when
they cast him for a director there's a
there's a kind of quite considered
lookbook kind of a whole tone created
with the script they they're done
together hand-in-hand and and I'd work
with Charlie through the kind of the
development of a treatment to script as
we push the tone so the whole thing was
put together as people started coming in
the process we were already aware ahead
of the curve and a night Phil said in
this instance we were talking about it
was brilliant other instances I'm having
to fly out somewhere many times and then
leave someone in charge and fly back
having set the tone and and just hope
that it all it all starts to carry on in
the way was made in the first instance
that dope you know the tone doesn't
start shifts just by someone but in it I
have got a good idea and as soon as I
left but and in this one is it was more
fun you know we're building sets in the
studio in London so actually it was a
bit more
of a joyful ride because you know we
could control it a little bit more I try
and look at in the interior of the ship
knowing that our biggest complexity on a
TV show that's a movie but a TV show
with a budget was going to be dry it was
going to be building something that both
of us were going to think was acceptable
on to our standards are quite high
actually and our taste levels are quite
specific there's a lot of geeks kind of
people who know a lot of things in in
black mirror but Charlie for instance is
a huge gamer no staff
Toby Haynes when he came on yeah mass is
moving relative oriya the first thing
was designed the interior of the ship
which we actually had to push because of
schedule so fast and so hard that it was
actually more of a JJ Abrams inspired
ship wasn't it initially yeah I mean
initially the the mood boards and the
discussions had been around the Infinity
game and the Infinity game was meant to
be a cutting edge space adventure elite
I guess type game with completely sort
of believable photo-real graphics and
the point of reference really was JJ's
JJ Star Trek very careful not to kind of
not to directly copy anything but at the
same time trying to give a nod to it
because of Charlie's take on on Daly's
involvement and his preoccupation with
the past and all that sort of stuff
and and actually what happened so we
pushed on very hard and and both of our
experience of working on those sets
before dictates that we know that some
of those finishes and the processors we
need to go through to achieve those
finishes require a lead time so if we've
got to send pieces of scenery away to be
CNC milled to dimensionally or three
dimensionally there's a lead time and
then we need to get it back and it needs
to be hard coated or molded and then
painted and and so you kind of work back
out of that and from the moment you
start you realize you perhaps got your
14 weeks from shooting but you've got
two weeks to draw up any elements have
you said that you want to get drawn that
way so the the approval process becomes
contracted super important and and
furious you know so we were we were
trying to get ill astray shion's out we
had a group of really Tantalus writers
jump on board and
helped us navigate the law and they were
experienced with a look as well so for
the sort of the common tech although we
I guess job plays with it every time
there's a script and there's a kind of
discussion with Charlie and they want to
tweak it there's a common language it's
a point in the process Charlie wanted to
sort of have a nostalgic feel to that he
came with a great idea
and that great idea suddenly were like
hey guys we'd already started making the
set I think yeah we're just kicking in
and I've got an idea we can make it
cheaper and we're like we're going to go
to the seventies tone or the 60s tone
and we were like oh my god it's gonna
look like we just we can't design sets
and this is gonna look terrible and and
so it kind of swayed the pendulums what
pendulum swayed in design a little bit
and ultimately what what we finally
worked out was it was gonna go there go
here and then end here and so that set
itself was going to have to transform
from a kind of nostalgic reality of it
something you'd have on a DVD in an old
format on television back in the 60s 70s
through to playing out as a real world
environment but still in that tone of a
slightly old-style
TV show moving up to the JJ Abrams TV
show and we had to make a set that
incorporated all of those things luckily
we weren't just scrapping what we were
doing and starting from scratch with a
crap set we were able to make a great
set that we kind of downgraded slightly
and may took into a kind of slightly
nostalgic period feeling in colors yeah
and then we realized actually it meant
we have to provide two sets and the
final set was the high end hard to
finish difficult sort of look
potentially if we were still trying to
match the the great sort of Star Trek
movies that thing I mean the last couple
of minutes of the movie were the
expensive bit from our point of view but
what we what we couldn't afford to do
was dumb that section of a movie down
because we wouldn't then validate that
the process we've been through for the
last 55 minutes watching
sort of 60s TV show so it's luckily it
stayed on track so we've got everything
we got it because I think Phil we
discussed it earlier Phil was worried
like if somebody starts watching that
black mirror episode and they don't
really know black mirror and we always
have to take a view that you never know
where someone's going to start watching
the show so any term when you watch
black mirror someone might just start on
a random 19 films I've made I'm pleased
I didn't I didn't make a dud I love them
all but the truth is you never know
where someone's going to start and you
want them to stay onboard you know and I
remember what the discussion was like
will they well someone just go and turn
it over but actually no it's balanced it
was balanced perfectly yeah homie Haynes
did a brilliant job didn't eat foods
yeah Toby was fantastic and Steph
passion the the DP embraced the whole
that you know we incorporated as much
light into pesetas we could partially
from just trying to copy the the sort of
look of the the JJ work but also to give
us an opportunity to you know turn
lights off change the look completely
wash colors across the set and Steph
embraced that and brought ideas of his
own to enhance that and push that on it
sounds really dull and he feels like you
want a really sort of gnarly story that
we can give you a book but the truth is
it was great and it was great fun and it
was really collaborative and everybody
sort of embraced the product and
everybody was excited about it you know
we're in this little studio in
Twickenham that's one of the homes of TV
and film making and we've got one and a
half little stages to ourselves and we
filled them to the walls it was just
kind of a laugh and I do remember you
saying though that I'm gonna be here
this is a nightmare I'm gonna look back
and think it was great no I did at one
point you actually said that yeah and I
laughed and went yep and I'm like I've
had this nightmare for two years I after
the first scene at the third season
someone said to me after they'd been off
for six months I've been done not
nosedive I think it was or Sanjana Peres
and they came back we were had a
screening six seven months later and
they looked a moment you still you're
still here aren't you they said I took
two months off after that show and I'm
like yeah I mean they're just say you're
right there's yeah it's great looking
back
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]